la jce marc daniel cohn bendit et
jacques sauvageot furent les leader de
mai 68
le nantais jacques sauvageau est
aujourd'hui enseignant mais il a suivi
de près les événements il les analyse
par rapport aux événements de mai 68 en
68 il y avait à la base une volonté de
réforme mais qui a tendance à l'être
mise de côté par deux autres éléments
le premier élément qui était en france
société qui est un mouvement de société
très très profond
l'évolution des rapports entre les
filles et les garçons par exemple la
communication plus de liberté et ainsi
de suite et c'est ce mouvement social
très profond qui est la marque
principale de 68 et puis il ya eu un
rapport au pouvoir aussi qui était posée
en 68
après 10 ans général de gaulle dont on
n'a pas eu ou qu'on n'a pas encore eu et
on n'aura sans doute pas puisque le
projet de loi d'être retiré quelle leçon
doit-on tirer aujourd'hui et cela alors
écoutez bien et je crois que la leçon
qu'il faut tirer de cela si la leçon
qu'on peut tirer aussi d'un certain
nombre d'événements qui sont passés
depuis six dernières années il faut que
l'enseignement évolue il faut que de
sociétés venues là on a l'impression que
dans ces mouvements là il n'y a pas eu
de tête charismatique il ya une
responsabilisation collective mais vous
avez en 68 jeux n'est pas plus trois
têtes
les médias avaient besoin
d'interlocuteurs et ils ont trouvé trois
interlocuteurs qui pouvait être un peu
disons les ne porte parole du mouvement
je crois que effectivement les étudiants
les lycéens ont pu être très responsable
parce que leur mouvement s'est situé sur
le terrain delteil diversiterre ils se
sont méfiés un peu de l'hyper
politisation du mouvement qui avait eu
lieu dans les années précédentes qui
avaient eu tendance à déboucher toujours
sur des mouvements minoritaires
[Musique]